alors les allemands est déjà difficile à
vivre en temps normal pour les personnes
âgées mais je l'aimé tant cette période
très difficile
on a pensé à un influenceur ce que je
peux dire du troisième âge michel
louvain bonsoir michel louvain vous êtes
an qu'elle enterre merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
bonsoir en dessous alors qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire
est-ce que vous avez au retour vécu le
choc de la situation d'ailleurs je les
véhicules je suis en quarantaine depuis
quelques jours parce que je suis un
sauveur alors je fais ma quarantaine
pour nous demander de faire et je suis
les règles du premier ministre il faut
faire ça c'est normal après les jeunes
les boumeurs s qui est un message que
vous serez tenté d'interpréter une
chanson ou même d'envoyer un message
particulier pour les convaincre du
sérieux vous vous preniez la chose au
sérieux mais il y en a qui sait
peut-être pas de majorité mais
s'approche je suis une personne qui
transmet le virus n'est ce pas mais
c'est malheureux parents parce que les
gens devraient coûter l'ailé les
professionnels de la santé qui disent
rester à la maison
inciter la maison de conduire de
s'asseoir dans salon il n'a pas bougé
moi je suis en quarantaine aujourd'hui
je suis allé à l'extérieur
j'ai profité du soleil j'ai pris une
marche j'ai vu très peu de gens et ça
fait du bien
il faut il faut la paix il faut que moi
je président il ressent de mon lieu de
2,2 d'affaires la quarantaine de rester
à la maison peut cependant faire le
ménage moi j'ai fait le ménage de mon
gars d'europe c'était le bon temps mais
c'est pas facile madame 10 aux tirs
respect à la maison ne sortait pas il
faut faire l'épicerie il faut faire un
tas de choses alors il faut changer son
système de vie ont le goût parce que
techniquement même après la quarantaine
quand vous avez plus de 70 ans je ne
m'abuse
vous pourriez pas techniquement à la
l'épicerie né à la pharmacie pendant que
quelqu'un vous aide quelqu'un
vous apportez les choses c'est aussi la
quarantaine risque d'être plus longue
comment vous préparez vous
psychologiquement à rester chez vous
allez faire une marche à l'extérieur les
pas en groupe
comment comment envisagez-vous cette
longue quarantaine dans sa devrait
dépasser 14 jours quand même mais seul
je le sais parce que premièrement en
arrivant mais spectacle était annulée à
cause confirmé les salles de spectacle
et on pense que ça va aller encore plus
loin
mais j'essaie de me préparer moralement
c'est pas facile c'est vraiment horrible
parce qu'on a on vit une situation qui
est assez difficile en ce moment mais je
me dis je pars seul sait le canada
lanthier c'est les états unis c'est
l'italie et l'espagne alors j'écoute les
nouvelles et j'essaie de voir ce que le
premier ministre nous dit monsieur
legault mais shabunda et j'essaie de
faire ce qu'on nous dit de faire et je
pense c'est ça qui est très important on
dit aujourd'hui en tout cas que le taux
de confiance aux taux d'approbation est
très très élevé cdc des records là c'est
important pour vous que de recevoir de
la part du gouvernement
cette communication claire et très très
forte sur l'importance de suivre les
lits consignes moi je vois mal un succès
très important d'écouter les nouvelles
voies ce qui se passe chez nous et aussi
dans le monde
mais par contre il faut pas paniquer il
faut pas se stresser
il faut un calme parce que la situation
c'est vrai que l époque et les poubelles
on sait pas ce qui va arriver mais il
faut être calme et prendre ça un jour à
la fois est assez de 2,2 de passer à
travers ces chiffres que nous les 70
avenue mois on va bientôt 83 ans parce
que je crois aussi un peu de ces
fragiles ou marchent le plus à risque
qu'une personne de 50 ans ou 40 ans
alors j'étais attention je donne que de
ma personne
youpi d'accolades jeu je me lave les
mains je ne sais pas combien de fois par
jour je me lave les mecs que je faisais
pas avant
alors aux grecs ont en cette pandémie de
virus nous nous apprend des choses que
on veut continuer à faire aussi
quand elle sera finie cette pandémie
j'espère bientôt on va continuer à faire
c'est aussi pour se protéger il y en a
question monsieur louvain vous étiez en
floride ya pas longtemps
là bas il y avait foule nombreuse qui
nous ont envoyé plein plein plein de
questions qu'est ce qui devrait faire au
retour
les gens disent bien les commentaires
qu'on abat moi ça me touche pas je les
ports on semble pas prendre
est ce que c'est parce qu aux etats unis
avait pas ce sentiment d'urgence qu'on
doit peut-être ici puis que peut-être
qu'ici on a des gouvernements exemplaire
qui nous amène sur la bonne voie vais
vous l'impression qu'en plus raide on
n'avait pas ce sentiment d'urgence là
ces gens là sont revenus avec cette
absence d'urgence la madame tussauds il
ya quelques quelques jours je
téléphonais mais un mythe
venez venez venez le plus vite possible
non non notre avion est 15 heures et
l'on pourra faire ou non venez
maintenant la plupart de mes amis à qui
j 10 sont maintenant et en option déjà
arrivé et d'autres sources des gens sur
la route et d'autres attendent leur vol
d'avion ils ont tous couper leur séjour
en floride mans parce que c'est pas très
rose non plus acer par certains peuvent
l'être at on dit qu'on ferme les plages
fait sur eric l'aviation et
professionnelle et intégrale même sur
une nouvelle on vous souhaite une bonne
quarantaine rester en santé pour qu'un
jour vous reste beau spectacle reprend
encore une fois ben merci d'avoir été
d'avoir joué le rôle de l'inflation pour
nous ce soir
j'espère que ça ait des gestes simples
aux légions les gens fassent attention
s'il vous plaît merci poté mai